piensa en la relación entre washington y vamos
chino y en el punto de mira para llegar
el informe de su país como socio
posición estratégica del país del sureste
de asia
impresionar losas de tensión
pasantías territoriales en y del mar
docena del sur son las misiones
del vicepresidente de estados unidos
kamal harris que actriz el miércoles
en la capital vietnamita hanoi
de mosca conocer forma de aumento
la presión sobre el régimen parache
que la convención de naciones
unidos por la ley del mar
excesivo
[Música]
casos todo el y estratégico mar decina
sureños que al laberinto de silicona
recursos y quédate ahí indicado porcina
mientras que vietnam brunei malasia tdp
nasti taiwán reclama ambos en parte
del mar el martes insinga pur de donde
comentario sobre visitar kamala en restavi ha
acusada alcina dientes version la
Choque de verdad Hawass
recriminación alaska y china tienen tarde
y respondo air mag pregunté por milos
se ahogó en este momento se unió a la
convención de entrenamiento objetivo
solo la marga y el mar, sin embargo, para firmarlo
acatar la convención ha estado en
milos inter minion accam instantes por quien
se desespera por mostrarle el poder de andros
interés de los países destaca la noticia es
sido su esposo dice que tengo un
mantener cremonioso a los que están solos
interés pienso en spa laura serani
mucho más como la visita de kamal
la dieta arista me ata en un momento
crítico para en washington la toma de
kabul estrellas porno libanesas sueltas o gruesas
como la evacuación de la capital afgana volver
en vivaro en el trauma de la guerra de
vietnam y la guía es 1970 el cinco de
diplomático estadounidense el saigón